season six I mean I'm not obviously not  looking for spoilers here but just  anything about the mood of the show or  anything that you can tell us it's gonna  be come out there's a lot of conflicts  happening inside and outside those walls  there's a lot of mistrust there's a lot  of Morgan yeah that there's this there's  there's so much going on right now  it's it's um I've even off the first  episode it's it's it's so powerful in  all these different directions and full  of tense energy that all of us just went  straight into it just grinding our teeth  and you can feel it you can see you know  a lot of sadness there's a rumor that's  very prevalent that one of you doesn't  get out of this season alive there's  always rumors this is more than just  people say that about you and me before  it's what it's been pretty sketchy there  a couple oh boy hey thanks for watching  please subscribe to my youtube channel  so they will stop making me shoot these  videos please